PROFESSOR: Hello,
welcome again to 8701.
In this short video, I'll talk
about the books we are using
and the literature we
are using in this class.
So let's dive right into.
There's a sequence
of textbooks I
go back to when I prepare
the material for the class.
You know, the one
which I use in order
to derive the outline or
the schedule for the class
is Introduction to High
Energy Physics by Perkins.
But again, I use
material from a sequence
of textbooks and reading
material for you guys as well.
Nuclear physics is not
covered in Perkins,
so we have here Samuel Wong's
book on Introductory Nuclear
Physics.
We spend about two weeks
talking about nuclear physics
towards the second
part of the class.
And a couple of basics, we talk
about the introductory material
really in the sequence.
A book I like a lot
is the Introduction
to Elementary
Particles by Griffiths.
And you see me using examples
out of that book a bit.
Then on the nuclear physics
side there is Kenneth Krane.
It's an MIT book
and a book which
has been put together by
MIT faculty and research
scientists.
And then there's Techniques for
Nuclear and Particle Physics
by Leo, which I like a lot.
It's a little bit
of an older book,
but it goes into some
of the technical details
and material details which
are important to understand
how we build detectors.
And then a more recent book
is Modern Particle Physics
by Mark Thomson.
It dives right into particle
physics, the energy frontier.
And it's really nice to read.
It's a modern book.
And it's easy to
read and comprehend.
I recommend to have a look
at the review articles
by the particle data group.
They are really
concise articles which
are for beginners or for
introductory level maybe
a little bit
difficult. But as we
go through the
material in this class,
you should be able to take
those articles to review
certain sections of this class.
For example, QCD, or
electroweak interactions,
the Higgs mechanism.
And while you do
this, you also learn
one of the latest results
and measurement in this area.
I'll be posting a set of papers
as we go through the class.
And you'll see in the
course organization
that I'll ask you to
actually summarize
some of those papers in
our recitation section.
So those are going to be
important papers, for example,
describing the
experiment which was used
to measure parity violation,
or the paper on the Higgs
discovery.
That's it for literature.
Please as always go ahead
and ask me questions.
You know this.
You know if you Google particle
physics or nuclear physics,
you will find tons of
literature available
on as many good books.
And you might find
a different one
from this listing which
suits your appetite
for reading and learning.